grand vivent en france le statut de
réfugié ou grâce à un titre de séjour
mais leurs femmes leurs enfants leurs
frères leurs soeurs vivent aujourd'hui
sous le joug des talibans food angoisses
sans aucune marge de manoeuvre une
vingtaine d'afghans sont venus ce matin
devant le ministère des affaires
étrangères à paris pour plaider la cause
de leurs proches l'état français est dû
qu on va excepté des familles qui sont
là et qu'on va aider pour les personnes
alors est ce que il ya il ya plus que
200 personnes qui étaient là il ya un
cas personne qui l'a reçue mail et à
anka père c'est qu'ils ont qu'ils soient
familiaux sont arrivés ici on nous
expliquer le terme sont saturés mais
voilà ça marche pas mais enfin alors je
veux dire on n'est pas capable de mettre
en place plusieurs numéros parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de demandes sophie veuf a
trois enfants à charge il s'est remarié
mais depuis trois ans son imposant de
ces de regroupement familial
appuyé par le maire de sa ville de
l'oise n'a pas avancé
son épouse n'a toujours pas
l'autorisation de venir mais aujourd'hui
l'heure est grave maintenant et d'étaler
bon pour ma famille a passé que le team
j'ai besoin ma faim il ya des papiers du
tout lié d arnaud mariage il ya des
pépites de maire de montataire il ya des
btan salaires deux fiches de paie avec
bon salaire il m'a dit attends attends
attendent jusqu'à mort et pas cher a
fait le déplacement depuis lille
paniquée par l'arrivée des talibans il a
envoyé un mail à la cellule de crise
dédié pour faire venir la mère de ses
trois enfants message restée sans
réponse les gens mais les dessins de mon
ya pas d les pourquoi les manger pendez
moi dans mon seuil de mémoire elle aussi
j'ai besoin maintenant de ramener pour
moi les emplois allait morfler de
membres dont le rapprochement familial
est pourtant un droit pour les
ressortissants étrangers qui se sont vu
reconnaître la qualité de réfugié ou qui
ont obtenu le bénéfice de la protection
subsidiaire mais les conditions sont
restrictives et de plus selon
l'association la cimade 3500 dossiers
sont dans les ambassades en attente de
traitement est quasiment la moitié a été
déposée il ya deux ans pour les autres
afghans bénéficiant d'un titre de séjour
sans protection l'espoir de faire venir
la famille est encore plus ténue magali
guadaloupe miranda coordinatrice du
collectif d'avocats qui défend les
personnels civils de recrutement local
s'émeut du sort réservé aux personnes
menacées techniquement les personnes qui
sont en âge et en afghanistan pourraient
demander un visa asile mais je pense
qu'on ne va pas se faire d'illusions ce
serait très étonnant que les ambassades
française d'un des visages il a toutes
les femmes isolées avec ou sans enfant
est néanmoins nous en tant qu'avocat on
fera tout ce qu'on peut pour saisir les
juridictions en urgence en disant même
si c'est du regroupement familial
j'estime que ce dossier doit être traité
très rapidement mais une fois de plus on
va engorger les tribunaux qui ont déjà
des délais délirant de traitement
parfois on est sur deux ans pour les
visas voire 3 devant primer un ministre
hâtif de nantes et et il n'y a pas la
réponse adaptée à l'urgence de la
situation il ne suffit pas de déjouer
les contrôles et fouilles des talibans
mais muni d'un papier des autorités
françaises les aspirants à l'évacuation
se font bien souvent refoulés dès
l'entrée de l'aéroport par les
américains cette fois un système de bus
est envisagée pour exfiltrer les
candidats depuis leur domicile de kaboul
le ministre des affaires étrangères jean
yves le drian a assuré que toutes les
demandes d'afghans sollicitant les
autorités françaises pour quitter leur
pays seront étudiées mais dans quel
délai encore une fois le temps presse
les américains envisagent un départ à
court terme et bientôt à cause des
restrictions des flux financiers les
afghans craignent de ne plus pouvoir
communiquer avec leurs familles une
course contre la montre qui pourrait
s'avérer fatal